que quand ils viennent vraiment et puis
ils me demandent de sortir je me demande
pourquoi et c'est là que c'est très
agressif ta gueule
et puis d'autres assument des insultes à
caractère racial mais sale [ __ ] ça
qu'on me l'a dit très grave n'arrivait
même pas le dire non il ya des familles
des enfants qui regardent au bout d'un
moment voilà c'est à ces écrits
qu'est-ce qui vous ont reproché à rien
je ne serai jusqu'à aujourd'hui je ne
sais pas ce qu'ils me reprochent
je sais pas ce qui me reprocher je sais
pas ce qu'il voulait je ne sais même
bien mieux que ce qu'on voit c'est ça
ouais donc y en a qui en civil dans la
cave en civil que je joue en premier et
puis après très vite je vois je vois les
deux autres habillés en policiers
mais vous essayé de leur parler vous
l'essayez de leur dire mais je suis seul
excuses officielles j'ai fait je sais
que sa série 6 fois je leur demande
pourquoi je leur demande valide beaucoup
pourquoi en fait oui c'est ça je garde
toujours les mains c'est ce que vous
dites dans la vidéo sur le site
l'outsider vous dites pas que je sais
c'est pas du tout et dans l'agressivité
parce que je veux pas vraiment qu'on
croit que j'ai pu attaquer les policiers
j'ai pu je dois clairon le voir dans la
vidéo vous êtes extrêmement calme
extrêmement d'hocine juge en caisse
voilà c'est ça et vous dit à un moment
je veux rester absolument debout parce
que si je me trouve
si je me mets à terre j'ai peur de plus
jamais relevé vous avez eu très très
peur j'ai eu très très peur
ah oui parce que je sais que je il ne
faut pas prendre des coups et je sais
qu'il faut que les enquêtes ça fait mal
ils mettent des coups de matraque des
coups de rangers dans les tibias
vous recevrez plus de vingt coups de
poing des coups de pied ont cinq minutes
des coups de genou de matraque vous fait
étrangler doigt sur vous vous essayez de
comprendre d'escroquerie y allait d'un
moment parce que vous savez boyer qui a
plus rien à faire ou crier à l'aide
je crie appelé la police mais c'est fou
est-ce que vous avez cru que c'était des
faux policiers ce que vous dites vous
dit peut-être que sinon ça m'a traversé
l'esprit mais tout va tellement vite que
après jeu
reste debout michel c'est ce que je me
dis